Hi everyone.
I'm going to talk to you today about a
book that I'm publishing in January of
2018 it's called 12 rules for life,
an antidote to chaos and it's going to
be published by Penguin Random House.
I'm going to tell you how it came about
first and then I'll describe the book's
contents and then I'm going to read you
a little bit of it.
Okay.
In 2012 I did a Canadian Broadcasting
Corporation program called say no to
happiness.
Um,
and in that program I critique the idea
that happiness was the proper goal of
life,
uh,
claiming it's dead,
that it's much more useful and
effective,
perhaps even for producing happiness,
to look for meaning and responsibility
in life.
Anyways,
I received the following email as a
consequence.
Dear Dr. Peterson,
your comments on the CBC program say no
to happiness.
We're both thought provoking and
challenging.
They had me asking bigger questions and
that has always tremendously appealing.
To be perfectly honest.
Some aspects were harder for me to
understand that others,
but I was left wanting to know more.
Have you considered writing a book?
For a general rather than academic
reader.
I'm a literary agent and Co owner at the
Cook Agency.
We have experienced with academics
interested in writing for a broad
audience,
working with them to remove the
scaffolding that required an academic
writing and helping to make their work
more accessible.
We specialize in selling authors to
international markets and developing the
writing careers.
You can find out more about us at www
dot cooke agency dot.
Ca.
I look forward to hearing from you,
sally harding.
So a literary agent represents an author
and attempts to market their books.
And so there they can be extraordinarily
useful people and in return for that,
they get a percentage of the book's
profits and that's how they make their
living.
So it's a difficult job,
especially now because the market for
books is while very complicated and
increasingly restricted,
I would say to a few extremely
successful authors.
Anyways,
Sally got Ahold of me and I had thought
about for a long time about writing a
more popular version of my first book
called maps of meaning.
And I actually produced almost a
complete manuscript.
Uh,
that was,
uh,
let's call it a,
a simplified version or I wouldn't say
simplified exactly more.
Well I tried to make it more accessible
but I didn't,
it was never really happy with it.
I never really felt that it,
that it got its legs underneath the tie
suppose.
Um,
and maybe that's because I was
duplicating something that I'd already
done.
I was thinking very hard about what to
do about this and how I might approach
it because sally was interested in,
I thought it might be a good thing to
try to write a book for,
for a more general audience.
And uh,
we talked for awhile and we discussed a
few ideas.
This was back in 2012 and uh,
I mentioned to her that I had written
something for quora,
which is an
online,
uh,
website obviously where anybody can post
any question and anyone can answer it
and then the questions are voted on and
a chorus quite interesting I would say.
And I had written a variety of out just
cause I was playing around with it and
some of them as it always is,
tracked it much more attention than
others.
Um,
and
okay,
somebody posted,
I think it was a young guy posted this
question,
what are the most valuable things
everyone should know?
And so I answered it.
I listed as it was 40,
42 rules to live by and some of them
were kind of amusing.
I thought some of them were dead
serious.
And anyways,
it became very popular on Quora and as
of now it has 174,000 views and 2,500 up
votes,
which makes it one of chorus most pop
popular answers.
How's,
it was soon after I posted it and I
thought,
well people really like those rules.
There was something about them that
appealed to them.
So what if I write a book based on the
rules?
And so I'll read you the rules.
Okay.
But maybe you'll find them interesting.
Tell the truth.
Do not do things that you hate.
Okay.
Which I think is a variant of telling
the truth because you have to act out
the truth as well as telling it,
act so that you can tell the truth about
how you act.
That's obviously related to the first to
pursue what is meaningful,
not what is expedient.
If you have to choose,
be the one who does things instead of
the one who is seen to do things.
Okay.
Pay Attention.
I assume that the person you are
listening to might know something you
need to know.
Listen to them hard enough so that they
will share it with you.
Plan and work diligently to maintain the
romance in your relationships.
Okay.
Be careful who you share good news with.
Be careful who you share bad news with.
Make at least one thing better every
single place you go.
Okay.
Imagine who you could be and then aimed
singlemindedly at that.
Do not allow yourself to become arrogant
or resentful.
Yeah.
Try to make one room in your house is
beautiful as possible.
Yeah.
Compare yourself to who you were
yesterday,
not to who someone else's today.
Work as hard as you possibly can on at
least one thing and see what happens if
old memories still make you cry,
right them down carefully and completely
maintain your connections with people.
Do not carelessly denigrate social
institutions are artistic achievement.
Okay?
Treat yourself as if you were someone
that you are responsible for helping.
Ask someone to do you a small favor so
that he or she can ask you to do one in
the future.
Make friends with people who want the
best for you.
Do not try to rescue someone who does
not want to be rescued and be very
careful about rescuing someone who does
nothing.
Well done is insignificant.
Okay?
Set your house in perfect order before
you criticize the world.
Dress like the person you want to be.
Be Precise in your speech.
Stand up straight with your shoulders
back.
Okay.
Don't avoid something frightening if it
stands in your way and don't do
unnecessarily dangerous things.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah.
Do you know how to let your children do
anything that makes you dislike them?
Do not transform your wife into a maid.
Okay?
Do not hide unwanted things in the fog.
Yeah.
Notice that opportunity lurks where
responsibility has been abdicated.
Okay.
Read something written by someone.
Great.
Pet a cat.
When you encounter what on the street.
Don't bother children when they're
skateboarding.
Okay?
Don't let bullies get away with it.
Write a letter.
The government,
if you see something that needs fixing
and propose a solution,
remember that what you do not yet know
is more important than what you already
know and be grateful in spite of your
suffering.
So those were the 40 odd rules and uh,
people were pretty happy with them.
And then something odd happened.
So a friend of mine as a novelist,
Gregg Hurwitz and Greg wrote a book
that's become very popular,
uh,
called orphan x.
And one of the characters in that book,
the female lead,
I would say off and on again wrote
romance interest for the main character,
posted these rules on her fridge.
And so they were peppered throughout the
book.
So that was kind of an interesting
development,
I thought.
And then because they were so popular on
Quora,
I talk to sally about the possibility of
turning them into a book.
And so my original vision was to write
42 short essays.
I thought that would be,
I was going to call the book 42 which I
thought was quite funny because if you
remember the answer to life,
the universe and everything from Douglas
Adams was 42 a computer calculated that.
So I thought it would be amusing to
write a book called 42 that,
you know,
contained answers to life,
the universe and everything.
But when I started writing the book,
um,
it turned out that I had more to say
about each of the rules than I had
originally envisioned.
And so I first cut it down to 25 and
wrote some essays and then I cut it down
to 16 and it was still too long.
And then I cut it down to 12,
which turned out to be a good thing
anyways because if you write a book,
you should write way more than you're
going to publish and then cut because
that way you,
you're only left with what's best.
So anyways,
I wrote for about three years.
While,
no,
it's more than that now.
I guess it's almost five years because I
just finished the book in September,
so it took about four or five years to
write and I was riding pretty regularly.
What I'm going to do is read to you a
little bit of it.
I think this is the book here
that's a galley copy and a galley copy
is a preprint of a book so that you can
get some sense of what it looks like.
It's got some nice illustrations in it,
I think by this comic book author named
Ethan Van Scriber.
So that's kind of a rough one.
Uh,
on the chapter three,
treat yourself like someone you are
responsible for helping.
Ethan is a comic book artist.
He's done a,
he's a great illustrator and he put my
kids in,
each one of my kids.
I have two kids,
one of them in each illustration sort of
contemplating,
well the complexities of life,
I guess that's how you might describe
it.
So that's one illustration.
I'll show you another one.
So that's my son Julian there looking up
at the great statue of David and that's
part and the David of course is an
inspirational statue.
It's a representation of what you could
be and that's real three make friends
with people who want the best for you.
And I think I'm going to read that,
some of that to you right now.
The each chapter,
each rule is divided into subsections.
Small sub chapters let's say.
And um,
I'll read you one of those.
You'll get some sense of the book.
Rule three,
make friends with people who want the
best for you.
The old hometown,
the town I grew up in had been scraped
only 50 years earlier out of the endless
flat northern prairie.
Fairview,
Alberta was part of the frontier and had
the cowboy bars to prove it.
The Hudson's Bay company department
store on Main Street still bought
beaver,
wolf and coyote first directly from the
local troppers.
3000 people lived there 400 miles away
from the nearest city cable TV,
video games,
and Internet did not exist.
It was no easy matter to stay innocently
amused at fairview,
particularly during the five months of
winter when long stretches of 40 below
days and even colder nights where the
norm,
the world's a different place when it's
cold like that.
The drugs in our town ended their sad
lives early.
They passed out in snow.
Banks at three in the morning froze to
death.
You don't go outside casually when it's
40 below on first breath,
the arid desert air constricts your
lungs ice forms on your eyelashes and
they stick together.
Long hair wet from the shower,
freezes solid and then stands on and
wraith like of its own accord.
Later in a warm house when it thaws bone
dry charged with electricity.
Children only put their tongues on steel
playground equipment once
smoked from house chimneys doesn't rise
defeated by the cold.
It drifts downwards and collects like
fog on snow covered rooftops in yards.
Cars must be plugged in at night.
Their engines warmed by block heaters or
oil will not flow through them in the
morning and they won't start.
Sometimes they won't anyways.
Then you turn the engine over
pointlessly until the starter clatters
and fall silent.
Then you remove the frozen battery from
the car loosening bolts with stiffening
fingers in the intense cold and bring it
into the house.
It sits there sweating for hours until
it warms enough to hold a decent charge.
You're not going to see out of the back
window of your car either.
It silver in November and stays that way
until may scraping it off,
just dampens the upholstery.
Then that freezes too
late.
One night going to visit a friend,
I sat for two hours on the edge of the
passenger seat in a 1970 dodge
challenger jammed up against the stick
shift using a vodka soaked rag to keep
the inside of the front windshield clear
in front of the driver because the car
heater had quit.
Stopping wasn't an option.
There was nowhere to stop and it was
hell on house cats,
felines and fairview had short ears and
tails because they had lost the tips of
both to frostbite.
They came to resemble Arctic foxes,
which evolved those features to deal
proactively with the intense cold.
One day our cat got outside and no one
noticed.
We found him later for frozen fast to
the cold,
hard concrete.
It's no lasting damage except to his
pride.
Fairview cats.
We're also at great risk in the winter
from cars,
but not for the reasons you think.
It wasn't automobile sliding on icy
roads and running them over.
Only loser cats died that way.
It was cars parked immediately after
being driven that were dangerous.
A frigid cat might think highly of
climbing up under such a vehicle and
sitting on.
It's still warm engine block,
but what if the driver decided to use
the car again before the engine cool
down and the cat departed?
Let's just say that heat seeking house
pets and rapidly rotating radiator fans
do not coexist happily
because we were so far north that
bitterly cold winters were very dark by
December.
The son didn't rise until 10:00 AM we
trudge to school in the pitch black.
It wasn't much lighter when we walked
home just before the early sunset.
There wasn't much for young people to do
in fairview even in the summer.
But the winters were worse than your
friends mattered more than anything.
So that's a little section of 12 rules
for life.
I can tell you what the rules are.
A foreword was written by Norman Doidge.
He comments a little bit about the
political turmoil that surrounded me
over the last year.
Although the book itself is very
apolitical with the exception of the
chapter on Skateboarding,
uh,
where I go into the battle,
the ongoing polarizing battle between I
would say the radical left and everyone
else.
Uh,
but other than that,
it's not a political book.
So the table of contents include rule
one,
stand up straight with your shoulders
back.
That's actually a bit of a story that
centers on lobsters to a large degree.
I,
I have,
uh,
what proclivity for talking about
lobsters rule to treat yourself like
someone you are responsible for helping.
That's something that people don't do
very well because they're not very happy
with themselves.
Often.
Rule three,
make friends with people who want the
best for you.
That's the chapter I already read that.
I read the first part of that and it's
about trying to organize your life so
that you're surrounded by people who
support you when you're trying to do
what's right.
It's very important rule for compare
yourself to who you were yesterday and
not too who someone else is today have
because if you're comparing yourself to
someone else,
I mean first of all,
you don't know very much about the life
of the person you're comparing yourself
to.
You don't know and it it no what across
all of its dimensions and second,
people are very different and so
comparing yourself to someone else,
it's kind of useful I guess when you're
young,
but as you get older and more singular
and more particular,
it becomes increasingly less useful.
Better to compare yourself to a previous
version of yourself and work for
improvement in that way.
Rule Five,
do not let your children do anything
that makes you dislike them.
That's probably going to be the most
controversial chapter.
I would say.
It's a chapter about discipline and love
and respect.
I guess that's probably right.
Rural six set your house in perfect
order before you criticize the world.
Yeah.
Well that's a rough chapter,
man,
that,
uh,
I'm trying to explain the mindset behind
people like the columbine high school
shooters,
and so it's a,
it's a harsh chapter.
Rule seven,
pursue what is meaningful and not what
is expedient.
Expedient is what works in the short
term expedience.
What's easy,
meaningful instead is what sustains you
through tragedy.
Let's say rule eight tell the truth or
at least don't lie.
Yeah.
Well,
it's not that easy to tell the truth
because who knows about the truth,
but you can learn not to say things that
you know to be false.
And if you stop saying things that you
know to be false,
then your life will improve the lot.
It's simplifies it and it puts you into
alignment with reality and you should be
in alignment with reality because
there's a lot more of it than there is a
view.
Rule nine assume that the person you're
listening to might know something you
don't.
That's a good one because,
and this is even true when you're
dealing with people that don't like you
because they may offer you criticisms
that are valid.
Now,
many that aren't too of course,
because maybe they're just trying to
take you down a bit.
But if you get a criticism that is valid
and then you can fix that error,
let's say that'll stop you from running
nose first into walls and that's
generally a handy thing.
Rule 10 be precise in your speech.
Yeah,
well you have to be exacting in the way
that you described things and the way
that you think because otherwise you
live in the fog and you won't get what
you should out of life or what you need
out of life.
And by need I mean what will sustain you
so that you don't become bitter and
resentful.
Rule 11 do not bother children when
they're skateboarding.
So that chapter's about,
I would say our society's hyper
concerned with safety and its
fundamental antagonism to exploratory
behavior,
especially among boys.
Rural 12 pet a cat.
When you encounter one on the street.
Yeah.
Well that's about trying to orient
yourself towards life so that even when
you're in the middle of a crisis or a
tragedy,
you can find bits and pieces of
experience that are positive and
sustaining so that you can stay
positively oriented towards your own
existence and towards existence itself.
So anyways,
that's the book
and it's coming out January 23rd.
Um,
although it's available for
preorder@amazon.com or amazon.ca and
several other places.
I'll put links in the,
in the video description.
If you're trying to figure out how to
Orient Yourself in the midst of the
chaos that constitutes life,
then you might find some of the things
that I wrote in 12 rules for life
helpful.
So I hope that that was interesting and
a good bye for now.